let's go to our next caller from the
nine-oh-nine area code caller from 909
who's this what's on your mind
hello uh David can you hear me yeah we
can hear you fine who's this okay my
name is Aaron I just had a question
regarding the political thing that kind
of blew up on social media regarding
Charley Kirk and shank tinder Jen Keeler
yes yeah thank you yeah I was kind of
you know oh yeah sorry I've difficulty
pronouncing it no no I was gonna just
ask them what do you kind of think that
kind of really why do you think that
reaction was just kind of provoked out
of a charlie Couric is he the right wing
especially like these new types of
pseudo-intellectuals like Jordan
Pederson they try to present themselves
as very calm I guess like consider it
like you know in debates and stuff like
this and here we just kind of saw them
just blow up out of like nowhere yeah so
listen for people who don't know where
you're talking about it politican over
the weekend there was a debate between
Jenks nephew Hasan [ __ ] and Charlie
Kirk of the right-wing turning point USA
I don't want to call it a think-tank I
guess it's like an activism group I
don't even know what to call it
and during that debate there was a point
at which there was a conversation where
I think Charlie was kind of probing
Hassan about how much money he makes
working for The Young Turks and it
escalated into a shouting match between
Jenk who was in the audience and Charlie
Kirk on the stage and Charlie Kurt got
up and walked to the edge of the stage
honestly I think it was all theatrics I
think it was just because Charlie Kirk
took the bait deliberately because he
knew that it would get attention and the
clip has gone viral I think that that's
all it is I don't think that it's a we
need to do an analysis of what was it
about exactly what Jenks said that got
charlie Kirk yelling off of the edge of
the stage it's just he knows it's
theatrics and this is what they do okay
yeah because and just think it's kind of
just ironic in a sense because they want
to kind of deliver themselves to be this
you know Bullock is like he they always
use like these these trigger words like
oh the violent laugh like you know the
civility of sounding college students
and all this and like he kind of just
showed like well I guess just just the
way whoa I don't know just the hypocrisy
of that he was like he knows that people
are gonna eat it up and like the fender
exactly yeah and by the way I don't
think Charlie Kirk is part of that
so-called like he's certainly not part
of the intellectual dark web which says
that it's all about just kind of like
calm and respectful engagement on the
ideas I mean if you saw I saw five
minutes of the debate between Hasan and
and Charlie Couric and it was just
shouting and it was so loud people were
leaving and saying it's just too loud in
there and it was there was nothing civil
about the tone or tenor of that debate
anyway so it's just the attrex and it
works you know yeah I guess it was like
a political it is like I was watching
the majority before and they were just
saying it's kind of like a comic-con
without more like morals or something
like that yeah absolutely it's it's
meant to be that way and and it was
thanks so much for the call really
appreciate it let's take a quick break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we are taking more calls after the break
don't hang up if you're holding will
take more calls momentarily